au départ il y a le châssis et les roues
d'une authentique amilcar des années 30
mais c'est celle ci toutes vêtues
d'argent qui a vu apparaître jour après
jour sa soeur jumelle des mains des
maîtres chocolatiers fabrice max et yann
c'est vraiment modeler c'est vraiment la
main donc on va rebondir du chocolat
vraiment l'air du chocolat et on va
monter au fur à mesure
la masse de chocolat un petit peu comme
un plâtrier j'avais à dire qu'il va
monter du platt nous avons fait un peu
la même chose mais avec du chocolat mais
c'est l'or noir mat au level fait 5 à 6
cm d'épaisseur minimum parce qu'il faut
que ce soit solide parce que là aussi on
va pouvoir monter dedans
en fait ce soit la très solide mais
c'est au moins ça de en épaisseur c'est
vraiment du chocolat qui est sorti de
chez couverture y est on a acheter du
chocolat en pistoles et on le met en
mode live façon modelage pourra remonter
donc le chocolat on peut le manger à
toute performance il faut des chiffres
pas moins de 260 heures de travail pour
un peu plus de 250 kg de chocolat et
comme c'est la première voiture du monde
tout en chocolat
les peintures des sièges du bois du
volant et les dessins des cadrans sont à
base de chocolat
mais pourquoi se lancer un tennis c'est
vraiment un beau challenge pour tout le
monde pour toute entreprise notamment
aussi pour les pour les apprentis pour
les chocolatiers c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui nous qui nous fait rêver qui
me fait avancer
demain 7 amilcar grandeur nature entrera
dans le livre des records
et si on doit lui décerner une médaille
ce sera évidemment une médaille en
chocolat